afternoon councillors ladies and
gentlemen welcome along to our august
meeting
um can you remain standing for the
opening prayer please father we just
come before you today give you thanks
for the privilege that we have of
sitting around this table and
deliberating on some of the most
important issues on the
district's calendar at this point in
time and we just pray for guidance and
wisdom as we make those decisions
tonight
amen thank you
okay um welcome again again councillors
um
we have two apologies that i'm aware of
uh councillor grant and councillor
bulger for lateness or maybe uh you
won't be able to get here at all
some would like to move those apologies
be sustained councilor mcdernell
signature council macphail thank you all
those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried
councillor conflicts of interest any
conflicts that councils would like to
declare at this point councillor heisted
thanks your worship
item nine over allocation of the
uppermontera river
just through my employment situation
i sit on the steering group that's
representing
irrigators and farmers
in the upper matera so i should declare
that interest now thank you
other conflicts councillors might have
no further thank you
um right we'll move on to the
confirmation of the minutes of the last
um
meeting of council
uh held on tuesday 12 july some would
like to move they'd be seen as a true
and correct record
councillor now signature council dixon
uh is there any alteration required to
that record
it does not i'll put the motion all
those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried
right that brings us on to um urgent
late business and we have two items of
urgent late business that need to be
transacted today
uh and councillors will have been
notified of those one from
environment southand who are going to
come and talk to us in fact they're here
now welcome along
come and talk to us about the evaluation
of the matera river stop banks in in our
district and some of the challenges they
are facing
and the second
item
relates to the appointment of a hearings
commissioner which will need to be
transacted in committee
would somebody like to move that those
items of urgent late business be
accepted please councillor davis
secretary councillor guarding
is there any discussion on that motion
there's not put the motion all those in
favor please say aye
against the motion is carried
in normal
processes that we will hold the urgent
late items to the end of the agenda but
i think that given some of the time
frames that
our guests have today we will move
straight to considering the item
relating to environment southend and the
matera
stop banks and would
welcome the delegation from environment
south and along
and look forward to what you
have to to share with us although it
might be with a little bit of
trepidation as to what you do have to
share with us so welcome nicole wilma
paul and randall
thanks for the welcome tracy and uh
great to be here but uh we'd like to be
here under under uh
more cordial and uh relaxed um
situations but thanks for the the invite
to come and give you a bit of a briefing
on
some pretty brick
breaking news we've had from from our
staff
as we're aware
we were successful in getting some
shovel ready money and there's been work
going on on the tower
and as soon as part of that we've had
some people probably with a bit more
expertise and flood banks
that have actually been having a harder
look at the whole fund bank system
and the preliminary report report has
actually
given us some reasonably disturbing
information that um there there are
vulnerable spots that in a high flood
event
may not have to be as high as it's been
in the past you could have a very sudden
um
collapse of a bank which could have
you know
catastrophic effects i guess and when
when human life is mentioned
obviously as a council we have to take
that seriously
this stuff
i won't go into the detail
but
when there's that sort of possibility we
we have to take a precautionary um
approach
it'll take some time to actually do the
geotech work and actually come up with a
probably a catchment-wide approach to
the river
you don't look have to look very far
afield either overseas or in new zealand
at the moment to
know that we're getting more and more
regular and
and more severe events than we've been
used to in the past
so um
i'm sure there'll be some question
questions shortly so i'll keep it brief
and i'll hand over to the staff to give
you a bit of a briefing there's a lot of
stuff we don't know yet but we felt we
needed to inform you and we want to work
with your council
going forward because if you have to
have a
evacuation and it's a lower level
understandably if people aren't aware
they may be reluctant
but
we need to put human health first so
thanks for the opportunity to speak and
i will hand over to paul
thank you thank you nickel and i just
noticed there is a little bit of
feedback from that mic so you might just
have to move around a little bit to get
get it right so welcome along randall
yeah thank you
sure nickel and thank you um mayor hicks
and thank you
council for and i was to speak to you
today um
so i'm paul holtz i'm the general
manager for integrated catchment
management and of which the
um the catchment operations team is a
function that reports to me so that's
why i'm here today and i'm joined by
randall beal who is our catchment
operations manager so um i'm going to
take you through a short presentation
i'm not sure
how you want to do this but certainly
i'm assuming you'll want to ask some
questions and whether you want to do
that at the end mayor or if you'd like
to do that through the presentation work
yeah look i think if um you can run us
through the presentation and then we'll
come back to you with questions okay
okay and is somebody able to
manage the slide deck
oh it's alright
oh is it over there okay
thank you
okay so just
a wee bit of background um matara stock
banks as you probably already know
there's about 100 kilo kilometers of
stock banks in the matara catchment
and that's been providing protection for
around
just more than 40 30 years and as you
well been aware the
2020 floods were quite significant and
they withstood
those record floods in 2020
and so the materia stock banks have done
what they were designed to do
but what the focus is now is what flood
protection is needed for the future
given that we've got things like climate
change
we'll talk to you also about
interdecardal pacific oscillation we'll
give you a little bit more detail on
that
and then general we're into of our stock
bank infrastructure
so that's a slide of basically all the
stock banks that we manage and operate
across the merihiku
region quite an extensive um
amount of infrastructure i'm just
i'll keep moving so i can deal with the
squeaking
so the situation is that we've had
assessments undertaken as part of a
scoping for climate resilience programs
and we've identified concerns about the
capacity and integrity of the stock
banks
so that work highlighted that we needed
to further further work further geotech
and to 2d hydrolic modeling which needs
to be undertaken in order to understand
really what we need to do to move
forward
but that also means
and that the urban communities gore
windham and matara
may need to be evacuated at lower levels
of what they've been previously used to
so the precautionary message that we
order being prepared
message is what we're really wanting to
highlight today and really what we're
looking for your assistance from today
as well
i'm just going to hand over to randall
and he can talk about as we're all aware
some of the climate change challenges
that are ongoing whether we're talking
globally or or or nationally
but also this inter decadal pacific
oscillation is also playing a factor
that we'd like to just spend a little
bit time explaining
thank you so part of the work that we've
been doing is not only uh looking back
at or looking forward but we need to
look back at what we've had and when
what we look
at here is a period of when the ipo was
in the positive phase roughly from 78
through to 98 and that's when the
ipo was in the positive phase
into the catal pacific oscillation
so following the 98 flood we had a
period of
relative calm with
22 years of no floods over a thousand
qmex
so when we compare that data and we look
at what neewer are saying about what we
need to
allow for for the next 20 years we have
to take that into account of what our
stock banks need to be able to contain
and deal with
so what are we doing the first priority
is paul setters the first priority is
the safety of the people of matera river
communities that's gore matera and
wyndham
this means they need to be prepared for
evacuations maybe more regularly than
what they've had to deal with in the
past and that is because
we're potentially going into a period of
greater and more regular flood events
so we have a forward work program
we need more info for matera and we've
got some specialists in and they've
identified that we need to undertake a
review of the integrity of those stock
banks so it should involve some
geotechnical work the geotechnical work
is essentially just x-ray
of the stock banks
this could be
evacuations at a lower river level and
we need to evaluate that on a
case-by-case basis
the flood events are different
and the ground conditions are different
in the stock bank conditions we're
different so we need to analyze those as
they happen and we do that by working
alongside ems and hydrology teams
we also need to continue to work with
gdc and the community and the other
stakeholders in achieving that
so the program of work for the short
term
we need to do some more investigations
so we can develop some options and bring
those back to the communities for
consultation we're working with ems and
communities to support
make sure that that's supported and
being prepared for evacuations
we need a stronger focus on flood event
analysis for forecasting and providing
communications to the community about
evacuations
we need to undertake some modelling
and geo technical investigations
and continue carrying out a stock take
on our current assets versus the steins
design standard we need to form an
infrastructure asset manager working
group because there's multiple
stakeholders across these assets so
we're doing keyword rail nzta et cetera
and we need to also continue to
investigate the medium and long-term
options
so if i would just uh
i suppose wrap up our main
focus today is to continue to talk about
the preparedness that we've we've asked
for the various communities to to
undertake were wanting to work with gdc
with your community to help do that and
help make that
as successful as possible
we've got a forward work program in a
number of these places so as part of our
climate resilience program we've got
work in
go we've got work in windham and we need
to do more work to understand what's
needed in matara
and we're going to with haste come back
with you working with you
to figure out some of the short-term
solutions to what's needed but in that
period and that could be up to six
months before we truly understand what's
needed
we need the community to stay prepared
and through this process
so my hicks i'll leave it at that
and if there's any questions
but uh thank you paul i'm sure there
will be some uh questions from
councillors
um but i guess the the questions i have
in my mind and you've talked about a
six-month time frame do you think what
in six months time where do you think
you will be at you'll you'll understand
the problem and you'll have a plan to go
forward is that right that would be that
that would be our uh expectation that we
have
um a good understanding of the
geotechnical and to do
so um
this is coming to light uh last week
yeah that has raised a lot of questions
in in communities mind about uh what
situation they're gonna find themselves
in should there be another flush and we
see some forecasts just in this this
week we're in now looking for some
pretty high flows coming through there
so
how will environment southland connect
with
the uh the communities of matera and
gore particularly
in terms of making sure that everybody
is
understands that the change the
challenge and and the answers that
that we need to come up with and and i
guess it may well be a question that
might be better directed to simon i'm
sorry simon to put you on the spot but
um
if if there is need for
more regular evacuations as appears to
be the case it may be
um
how prepared are
civil defense ems
and uh our
team here to get that off the ground so
just interested in your thoughts on
those really really good questions if
simon wanted to
jump up he feel free but i think i'd
start with that we've got you so
cyphon's got a history of managing as
well
and in the last words and
the evacuation of um
goal or parts of goal went really well
and so there's a really strong
working relationship with ems
and the second point i make is um we do
have the benefit of a longer leading
time than other areas
so we are to experience high rainfall
in the upper catchments in some cases it
can take up to 12 hours to come down so
we've got a lot of time to plan
you've also got communities that are
used to this
way
and in in the last floods i'm informed
that the tower community were really
proactive and responded really well
and so we'd be
likely to build off that community
support
and then really the confidence that i'm
supposed to be looking through is the
way the environment cycles and emergency
management certainly working together
operationally to look at forthcoming
events that's part of our internal
approach where we're taking a weekly
view of this
and every rather event we'll take on
case by case basis so if we need to we
can we can swing into action pretty
quickly but i'll hand over to simon
because he might have some extra bits
uh thank you kiera koto uh co simon matt
tucker lingard my name is simon i'm
currently the group manager and the
group controller for emergency
management south and which is the ens
everybody's been referring to
as you probably know we work reasonably
excuse me i'm trying to get this so it
doesn't squeal but
we work reasonably
close with all of our councils
we're a shared service at this time
this one should uh not make me squeal as
much hopefully
so we work closely with all the all of
the councils and especially with our um
ces and our elected officials
um as you've heard from um environment
south and there is a challenge uh anyway
without this news coming up with the
change
in climate change and
the possibility of extra events where
there's going to be
bigger downpours of rain over a
shorter period of time
what i suppose i would like to just
reinforce with the council today is that
we have 24 hour on-call ems staff
monitoring the situations as we do with
environment southland hydrology staff
as paul uh pointed out
this unlike many other areas such as
taranaki or the west coast means
that we have a lot a long leading time
and let me sorry let me correct myself
there due to the size of our catchments
we have this long lead in time so in the
2020 floods we were able to provide a
lead-in time of somewhere about nine
hours before the actual
surge of water came through
um
once we heard uh from randall and his
team about the issues in matada we got
together with them um and the
hydrologist and we're looking at an
assessment team where we can actually
look at
modified trigger levels to actually
provide to our elected officials to give
them information to make
decisions on declarations
as you probably understand if we are
approaching our elected officials our
mayors to make those declarations
um we are trying to do it at the uh best
time possible so we're looking at the
big lead in time but at the same time if
we can see something escalating during
the
daylight hours then we'll be advising um
the mayors
to actually think about uh declaring
early anyway we've done this in the past
um and we use a system called the um
ema so that's the mobile alert system
that you got through covered
and in the 2020 floods we use that to
do two things one is put a message out
to evacuate voluntarily
and then once a declaration happens then
we
tell people to get out as there is a
declared event
um
i i suppose it is um
incumbent on me just to highlight that
we're a shared service so
we're working with all four councils uh
to ensure that we give the best
information at the time and let me just
reinforce that we do have that 24-hour
surveillance happening
we have flood plans and we are
well-versed at using this i believe
there's going to be drop-in sessions in
the matada community
and emergency management south and we'll
be uh providing the new national
messaging of get the flood out which
would be
part of that drop in session so that
people of
the residents of gorham masala have some
information around that and i think
i think it's
also good to mention that it's actually
good to have this information out for us
as people that will be asking
people to evacuate early
once you've asked people to evacuate i
guess there's nothing worse than
the river slug going through
and nothing happening and then people
kind of saying well why did you evacuate
us
we do understand that an evacuation is
an extreme event that puts a lot of
people and businesses
at uh at some kind of discomfort so look
i i will welcome any questions but i
just thought i'd come along uh possibly
bully my way up to the stage
thank you mayor hicks for asking me to
do that uh just to tell you that uh we
are monitoring the situation
well thank you simon and uh just before
i open it up to
to counselors who i'm sure will have a
number of questions i guess the the
other thing that i have on my mind is
you know whatever the result of the
investigations over the next six months
is going to be a pretty big project
and
it's probably going to take a lot of
time but it's also going to take a lot
of money
and and i'm just wanting to get some
reassurance as to where the financing
for such um construction as we're
talking here
might come from
so that's a really good question so um
a a reasonably significant part is being
managed for the climate resilience
program so that's the um i alluded to
that that's the working goal and that's
a work in windom
and that's not to say that we wouldn't
look to do over time additional work and
additional resilience work additional
strengthening and part of this um
part of this work we've got to we've got
to quickly come up to speed and what
with what we need to know and that's the
geotechnical work and the 2g
hydrological work and that'll give us a
better understanding of what's going to
be needed
for us to then as a as a as a regional
council and to work with our other
stakeholders what options
do we need to do going forward in terms
of finances so that will be
a continued work in progress and but i'm
assuming that as part of that we'll be
coming back and talking to the various
partners and stakeholders to develop
that
i think nicole's about to come up to the
podium as well
to mention money and nickel appears
just to add to that we we need to find
out what the scope of the problem is
we probably will be looking for your
support
to go to wellington we know there's been
some shovel really money we would
certainly put up a good case
there may be another round next year we
don't know
but we'll have to work through that but
the the reality is you're right there's
probably going to be some local costs
going forward even though it's spread
over a long period of time like the last
time
where we don't want to be alarmist we
need to actually find out what the
problem problems are
and you know after 84
with invercargill the pro banks were
probably pretty new
probably better the old i'm told it's
like a pyramid if your base if your base
isn't strong
we you've got
problems so if we start putting more on
something that hasn't got a good base we
not may not be helping
so we'll work through that we may well
need
out of invercargill we put in a couple
of retention dams to slow water down
and there's least land we own that's uh
that is sacrifice
prepared to be sacrificed to save the
city i think this is going to be a bit
more comprehensive than just patching
the flood bank but
yeah we don't know at the moment we've
got we've got to work through it work
with you guys to actually find out um
what we need for the next 50 to 100
years to protect our communities
well thanks nicole and you can be
assured that as council we'll want to
work with you as well so but um open for
councillors um
john
um yeah we're just talking about the
early warning um signals for gore and
matera and we have another river it
comes in called the wakaka and we used
to have an early warning level with
willa bank and it says data on that but
that's been taken out
and i mentioned last time you're up that
you should be reinstating that
because that gives us two or three hours
warning for the waikeka and if it peaks
the same time as in terror peaks we're
in real trouble most times it's gone
through
but the only spawning only level we have
is at escort and that's when the river
is right there
so
it's really crucial that you have those
early warning
things on the river especially waikeka
because it comes in their back door like
in
and gore here and dams up the material
and pushes over the name
i wasn't aware of that but certainly can
take that away and come back and but
thanks for that yeah i think randall you
took a note of it here yeah
okay any other question counselor
thank you your worship um question for
simon
in the last flood um
a lot of our council staff were here
were at the coal face right from the
word go
um and contacting people and there's two
issues
the manpower thing and the fact that a
lot of people weren't connected and had
no idea until people knocked on their
door that anything was really going on
and i think that's something that you
really need to be
i don't know how you manage that but i'm
sure you'll have a good plan
and the other thing is too is that
matera
matara's response was probably the best
response in a lot of ways and that was
driven by the local board and local
town people and
so what is your connection going to be
with those people in those groups
going forward because not everybody is
connected as i said and sometimes for
some people it's a bit of a shock
yeah thank you for that uh question
councillor um we work heavily uh through
our community plan system um where we
actually uh in peacetime actually make
connections with our communities
we have community plans and
there is a community hub
set up that we have ready to go that
does utilize
people from the community as you as you
pointed out
um the reason we do that is because
emergency management southland is six
people strong and in the 2020 floods if
you remember
we actually deployed people to tiana to
deal with the fjordland flooding which
was the first event
and then i believe some of those staff
came down to gore and we also
deployed some emergency management
assistance team from directed by nima
to assisting gore you are correct though
we we rely heavily on the on the
communities
that
it is
a recognized thing that communities do
that organically anyway but we just want
to give them
a structure to follow
and that's what ali curd and her team do
and they do it on a regular basis and as
i say there are community plans
thank you
one thing i will say too is that perhaps
going forward given that there's going
to be elections at the end of um towards
the end of the year
there will be changes on those community
boards at wyndham and the tower and for
those people that may be completely new
sure so perhaps speed is of the essence
correct thank you
the the first of the community meetings
is on
the friday the 19th in matera i think
the first gore one is on the 22nd but
they're all up on the website so over
the next couple of weeks there will be
an opportunity for the community to come
along so god if you guys can publicize
that too because the more people that
are aware of this and can come and get
their questions answered i think the
easier it'll be going forward
one point with the community meetings
which is great um and awesome
um they're all pretty much during
daytime and you know there's a lot of
workers in both materia and gore so
making time for them to
to come out of
normal work hours would be much
appreciated
look if that's an issue tracy let us
know and i'm sure we can arrange an
evening one
as well so if there's a demands there
i'm sure we'll we'll find a date for it
uh nick cool uh probably thanks your
worship um
for the matera river do you have a river
stability and flood management plan
not as as you've described it no right
uh one more question um
soil conservation rivers control act
1941 planned gravel removal at specific
locations as necessary for maintenance
of flood channel flow capacity and
integrity of the flood banks will that
be something you'll be looking at as
well
our strategic gravel management
management is our best
river management tool that we've got
available
yeah cool yeah just just looking through
the country hawke's bay and bayer
clinton have been doing it for 50 years
for river stability
and
flood management so it seems to work
pretty well with them
thank
you
one of the other issues we have to deal
with on the material is the conservation
order and you know there's a lot of
anecdotal um evidence that there is a
gravel build up in places
and i think
we will have to have a look at the whole
package and we probably need to get some
of those parties and actually have that
conversation because
it's it that's that's not the silver
bullet but it may be well
one of them
you know
how narrow it is there it's matara so in
a high flood
the pressure that's putting on going for
that narrative channel that's one of the
first things that's been identified that
if we get longer events saturated flood
banks etc something could happen quite
quickly
but
in my mind i'm thinking we may have to
look at diversions further up uh so you
can take the pressure off
after the sediment trap would actually
be good for water quality going forward
too i think we're going to have to look
at
some of these issues that with different
eyes than we perhaps have in the past
for the last hundred years we've tried
to speed water up and uh for drainage
purposes but actually we may have to
slow it down to take the peaks to take
the tops off some of these peak events
certainly a a strategic view of the
whole river system is pretty important
and and much more that much more
important i think than looking at the
specific pinch points where
overflows have happened in the past and
and just given what we're seeing not
only
nationally but around the world
we just can't keep building banks higher
and higher
to keep the water out we've got to do it
a different way and it's good to hear
that you're open to those those
opportunities
other question glennis
thank you worship
it is pleasing to hear you speaking
about water capture because for two
reasons one would be
taking some of that pressure off the
flood banks and the other one is for
water allocation as well to help out
people in the dry
times and the other
other
thing that i'd like to to raise is
there's a lot of talk about allowing
rivers
to find their own way that we can't keep
as the mayor has said putting them into
channels
yes i guess that's all going to be
considered within within this
yeah and just to
again really good comments and i suppose
our
primary focus is to come back as early
as possible with more information so
that we can better inform
the solutions so the solutions and
most likely will be have a long short or
a medium term
and and so we need to um we need to do
that work in order to come back to
figure out what what those things can
look like but uh as nickel has alluded
to some of the longer term options and
can be quite quite broad for sure yeah
thank you um brett you had a question
then uh richard
you thanks tracy i think it's a question
for paul you've talked about evacuating
at a lower level and that's out in the
community and it's a case-by-case basis
but have you got any context in this
point as to what that might mean
um
not not at this stage but
you can be assured that we're watching
it regularly simon's alluded to that we
will um that will manage it and with
some precaution in mind that that the
the implication of that means that um
the communities need to get you know you
need to get used to being evacuated at a
much lower level where that risk might
not be as apparent but we're
going to need your support and support
of the community to do that i think once
we get the geotechnical information in
and the two the 2d hydrological
modelling we'll have a better idea of
what those levels
might need to happen at but we don't i'm
maybe simon's help me we tend to want
every um case on every river to do a
case-by-case assessment as well so
there's never ever
a really specific level and it just
depends on a number of factors that they
decide as and when those decisions are
being made but maybe i'll bring simon in
to just clarify sure
thank you for the question um
in other areas such as west coast and
taranaki as i pointed out before they've
got a very short catchment area
and they have specific trigger levels
which means that they evacuate towns at
a certain
a certain q max
that's not the case
necessarily with southland we have much
longer
catchments as i'm sure you all know
and that affords us a lot more uh
information and time to prepare people
to evacuate
that said it also offers a bit of
complication in the fact that there are
tributaries further down the catchment
that actually increase or decrease
certain flood events
so we've got to pretty much map it as it
goes down
as it goes down the catchment so
at the at this particular stage we don't
have a specific trigger level what we do
is we keep an eye on the mat service
with its warnings
we
rely heavily on the hydrology team at um
at environment southland they have
certain trigger levels that alert us
and then we make contact with randall
and his team in the catchment management
area and uh his team are out on on foot
looking at their assets uh as the flood
is coming through
so so in terms of conditions the last
flood event we had
there would have been a shift i guessed
in the evacuation time frame on that is
that a reference point or not
the last um the last evacuation i was a
an alternate controller at the time and
not employed by emergency management
southland i was however
on the night shift and if memory serves
me correctly i think about three o'clock
in the morning we decided it was time to
start thinking about evacuation of the
uh of the urban centers down the matada
and at three o'clock i think that
afforded us all the way through to 12
o'clock with the information that we had
12 o'clock the next day
yeah thank you worship um
council hostage actually asked a couple
of things that i was going to check out
anyway um
in regard to the infrastructure asset
manager working group where does gore
council fit in that like where where's
our conduit or the information that's
going to come back to us
how does it work
yeah the first part yeah well maybe
randall can speak in a little bit more
detail but that's what we would like to
set up reasonably quickly in order to uh
so we'd be looking at a
gdc representative to join us at some
point with the other tas and the other
the other partners so maybe randall you
can talk about more of the detail
thank you mike the main thing with
having the working group is that no
one's duplicating the effort so when
we're undertaking modelling or
investigations it is one source of the
truth so we will be looking for
co-funding for some of this from various
parties
uh the infrastructure
stakeholders across this area is
obviously kiwi royal nzta
and across the region is the district
councils as well as uh fonterra
thank you
um and just the second part is probably
for the chairman uh in regard to
where are we at with central government
discussion and notification around we've
obviously got a problem on your back
door
um you said that you might be getting a
worship uh emir to go and make some
representation in wellington but clearly
there's a large check somewhere
we're going to have to find some funding
to push this and it may be a bit beyond
what we've got sitting in our back
pockets at the moment so
with some experience i'd say too right
our staff will has been having
conversations
over some of the shovel ready money
we've already had some things are gonna
cost more than we thought
and the conversations were about around
can we use the money to prioritize uh
they're not
that easy to work with they put out
shovel really money and now and they'd
like to take away again if they could
but
the big push from the regional sector to
get this funding in the first place and
where the found pandemic probably put it
on quicker for
for jobs was to point out to government
that actually they've got a lot of
infrastructure that's at risk and
therefore um really there should be some
an investment
those
discussions will continue
we we were reasonably successful the
first time around and we only had a very
short time to put in bids
if there's a if there's a silver lining
to this
situation we've found is
if there is another round next year
we're going to be well prepared
and but we know we'll we'll start doing
things as soon as we as soon as we know
where the high risk areas are but
really we need the time to get to that
detailed assessment um you know
higher flood floods we've seen on the
west coast and further up saturated
flood banks
i understand some of the front banks
around this area might go back almost
100 years
and i guess the
the geotech work will tell us what what
the base of those things are like
because the top might look alright but
if you put more pressure on something
that's got a poor base
you actually might exacerbate the
problem
so it certainly will
we'll have tracy in the loop he's
he's been wellington a bit so
we found in the past that if southland
can speak with one voice we've got a
better chance of actually getting
traction on wellington
um
okay councillors is there anything else
um i think we've covered a fairly wide
gambit there but certainly this is an
issue that's uh top of mind for us and
one that we want to play a part in as
much as we possibly can so
i'm really looking forward to
making that partnership or that
relationship stronger between ourselves
and environment south and particularly
around river management and if you think
there is any way that we can be of help
in terms of twisting some arms then
only too happy to to provide that so
thank you nichol uh and your team for
coming along at short notice uh to just
give us an update on on where you're at
so clearly uh a fast moving situation
and um and one that we're all incredibly
interested in so so thank you and i wish
you well
thank you
thanks for the opportunity
okay um councillors just before we move
on with
the rest of the um
the agenda i just want to make a couple
of comments and
particularly firstly i just want to
congratulate those councillors that have
been re-elected uh unopposed uh
councilman mcdonough councillor guardion
and councillor phillips it's really good
to see um there's going to be some
consistency and continuity around the
table i'd like to think there might be
some more coming but
certainly the base is there now and
it's just it's reassuring to see the the
faith and the trust that your
communities have in you to to do the job
to represent them so well done and
congratulations
um also um today i think for the first
time we've got two of our new general
managers in the room at a council
meeting and we've got risk capital and
jason domigan i think jason probably
your second day so
a fast-moving situation you're uh you're
finding um but steve perhaps so i could
get you to just outline the councillors
the roles of these two um two gentlemen
going forward
yeah thank you worship so
rex is positioned as general manager
community lifestyle services
so that really embodies all the place
shaping uh activities that we have at
the council so involves arts and
heritage
aquatic facilities all the multi-sports
complex
libraries
and parks and reserves
so that's rick's portfolio
jason has got the new title of general
manager critical services and is very
timely to receive the presentation this
afternoon from environment southern uh
jason's portfolio uh encompasses three
waters
and the position is really
aimed at uh three waters and
if there's reform to proceed uh in terms
of facilitating that reform or being an
advocate for uh service for the
community should the again that reform
uh come to pass
roading is under his um
uh solid waste or waste minimisation uh
a topic of which is on the agenda later
this afternoon
uh climate change
and emergency management so all those
critical services
and activities that
go to the very heart of what a local
government unit is about that comes
under jason's jurisdiction so that
really completes the
restructuring of senior management that
was embarked on earlier this year
thank you steve and congratulations and
welcome rex and jason great to have you
on board
okay councillors we'll move on then to
our next item which is just the the
minutes of the creative communities
assessment
um committee
so would somebody like to move that
those um
minutes be received please
councillor reed
double seconder for that
council davis any
comment from councillors if not i'll put
the motion all those in favor please say
aye
against the motion is carried thank you
right we'll move on then to matera
community board
and we have the the minutes of the last
meeting of the community board which um
need to be received and um
ratify any recommendations that might be
contained therein
and also to the opportunity to ask some
questions of community board members if
uh if councillors have any is there any
questions of
the minutes
council heisted
thank you i was just looking at the item
for
matera communities into building
maintenance
um
and the chairman asked that the concerns
being raised with council
i just wonder if there's any additional
information the council
could think can we share with the
council at this point
in relation to that
future report
look i'm not sure that i haven't seen
any more information but probably that
will form part of a report coming to
council i would think
i guess the way it raises it's just
totally missed but is the point that
it's within an existing
budget that wasn't exactly clear at that
meeting i guess that
if you read that face value
it suggests
something i think that's incorrect so it
would be good to have that clarified and
i guess the other thing
i just want clarification on item six
the additional engineering cost of three
thousand is to be noted to council as it
noted on the basis that the council
should meet those costs
okay um
any comments other comments counselors
it's not
that was a question
if there's no answer i'd i'd probably
suggest that for an additional cost of
three thousand dollars to assist the
community award getting the signs in
place the town the council should
just agree to that by moving the minutes
okay yeah so you're moving both
recommendations
yes i will great thank you councillor
hosted driver segmenter for that
councillor phillips thank you
uh any further comment there's not i'll
put the motion all those in favor please
say aye gates the motion is carried
thank you councillors
right um we move on then to uh southern
fuel days upgrade
[Music]
upgrade of entrance
and we have a report from the chief
executive
looking at a challenge that's been
ongoing for some time
and
really for the field days to progress
needs to be addressed reasonably soon so
it's the chief executive
thanks your worship this
stems from an invitation that southern
field days extended to
myself yourself your worship and
a couple of senior councillors
to come out to the
property at waimumu and just to be
i guess given a briefing of the the
executive committee's
plans recent achievements and future
challenges
and during that conversation
there was talk about
a resource consent condition um and
initially the
discussion was centered around
whether that condition could be extended
time-wise because
once they can when the consent was
originally granted it was just prior to
the um
uh the
impact of covert 19 and really nothing
further took place for the ensuing two
years
um but it was during that conversation
it's fair to say that
while the committee was certainly
receptive to any assistance it could be
um
offered uh a number of us thought gee
this is actually our roading asset that
is being we're at the the the consent uh
asked to be upgraded
and is it reasonable that
all costs lie with the applicant being
the southern field days
executive committee
particularly given that there are a lot
of events that are held out there small
events community-based
free of charge
and
some of us thought that
it really was a
valuable community asset and perhaps the
community should make a contribution
to upgrading the entrance which will be
enhance traffic safety with the idea of
a slip lane and a right turning bay
and those of you have been to the end
particularly the annual field days um so
the biannual field days event can see
that traffic management is a major part
of the challenge that the committee has
so that you couple with the fact that it
is our roading asset it's going to be
enhanced and
it's a
a not-for-profit society
putting forward a lot of exciting events
and creating community well-being
both economic and socially
it seemed to be
a strong case for the council to make a
contribution
and with that presentation
as the
the fact that over the years the
council's assistance
has been you'd have to say reasonably
modest
financially uh given
the type of
activity conduct on the site the scope
that's the largest agricultural event in
the south island we've assisted in lots
of um consenting marquees and a bulk
discount fee for that and in recent
times we've also uh funded the traffic
management plan
but uh we've been looking at
the roading asset itself it is our asset
it's going to enhance the asset enhanced
traffic safety
and it seemed to me that a partnership
between the council and southern field
days would be in order
and given the type of work involved it
will also attract a subsidy so
it's now before you worship for uh
consideration
thanks steve um and certainly from my
perspective i think it's a good
recommendation a win-win for for the
community and and also for the field
days um
but it's open for councillors to
make any comment council davis then
councilman fail thank you
i fully support the recommendation uh
they bring an enormous amount to the
community
not just with field days so i fully
support it and i'll be prepared to move
it
thank you nikki um
councilman
yeah just uh basically through worship
um obviously through the community and
the community strategy side
uh fully support that you know the group
um
it's a writing asset uh it covers all
the bases it's almost a coin and phrase
and a no-brainer from from from that
that side of it and we have had very
little
uh input so
i fully support that motion that's there
so you're prepared to secure that
councilman file yes
okay any further comment or questions
counselor
dixon
thank you worship um i'm fully
supportive of this as well because i
know there's a lot of community
fundraising out there and so they're not
coming to council cap in hand to get
fundraising and they can
make quite a lot of
fun funding for the for non-profit
organizations so i support it as well
thank you
any other comments
uh councillor grant
just with the um big push in the in the
nation at the moment um could we
approach nzta about getting a walkway or
soccer way out there as well
i don't know that's being considered but
beautiful scenery out there i guess
all all ideas are welcome and yes we
will suggest that
okay uh councilmaker now
um
i just had one a wee bit of a different
thought i think different sometimes um
i'd never noticed that
we we probably should have um vetted
their accounts this is like a grant
and and they had a look and see how
financial they were but i do agree it's
a good thing but the other thing you
could do is subsidize it take more on
and
take more of the project on so we get
more subsidy from transit
and then horse trade air
traffic management
so we don't pay for our traffic
management for five or ten years
does that make any sense in other words
you you leverage another bit more by
taking more of the project you leave
them more from transit for only a 59
subsidy and then
we wouldn't donate our traffic
management for five or six years
okay look i'll ask the chief executive
to make some comment but i'm also
mindful that we have a motion on the
table
um i'm going to be a classic midfielder
your worship and flick it to the roading
asset manager because he will know more
about the mechanics of actually applying
for wakitahi funding
rather than me trying to hazard a year
so murray can you just
proffer an opinion about whether
the council
assuming i'm i'm assuming from the
council garden's question that if the
council
took almost ownership of the project
globally
uh could it receive a large chunk of
subsidy is that correct well i think
murray can answer that question
through worship um i think we
may be pushing the envelope a bit
um if we went down that track
the i think the items that
we've mentioned in the report uh
uh are specific items that
are justified to
receive ncta funding or
subsidised funding but
i think
um some of the work beyond that uh would
be quite difficult to
to justify uh to ncta that it meets the
uh meets their requirements
murray
okay um take on board the comments
you've made um council guardians
okay we have a motion which uh reflects
the recommendation on page 28 so um
there's no further comment i'm going to
put that motion all those in favor
please say aye against the motion is
carried thank you
right we'll move on then to item 8 and
resource
management delegations
and we have a recommendation from the
chief executive
for some changes in this area
a very straightforward worship uh when
these delegations were initially
prepared
was at the commencement of the property
group's engagement as
preferred
senior planning consultant for the
council
and some of the individuals within the
property group weren't as well known to
us
and therefore there was some difference
in some of the staff delegations that
were recommended katrina alice is a
senior planner who does the full range
of day-to-day functions for
consent processing so i personally deal
with katrina we have a
meeting each week
and she leads the the consent processing
arm of the council as distinct from matt
hill where some of the the district plan
review subcommittee members will be very
familiar with matt who really leads the
district plan
um in the policy area so it's an order
for katrina alice to be given the full
range of delegations to enable her to
quickly discharge her duties on behalf
of the council thank you
okay councillors any questions of the
chief executive from the ministry
respect
councillor davis i'm happy to move it
thank you dave seconder
secondary councillor phillips can you
comment does not put the motion all
those paper please say aye
gates the motion is carried thank you
counselors
right that brings us to item nine and um
an interesting
concept that we're
faced with at the moment
um over allocation of water of the upper
matera and so this relates to the
conflict that councillor heister
declared earlier on uh look i'm
comfortable that you remain
at this point in time
um
okay so we have a report from three
waters asset manager i think it's pretty
self-explanatory but matt do you want to
just talk us through this and outline
any or answer any questions counselors
might have
yeah thank you worship um yeah so this
is obviously an issue that has um i
guess been floating around for a couple
of years now
uh since it was discovered that the
matara river or the upper matara river
was over allocated
um
[Music]
at this stage it's believed that the
over-allocation is an over-allocation on
paper only um and so
what i mean by that is that
there's a lot of takes that aren't using
their full consented allocation
and the hope is that the
the over-allocation can be addressed
through
voluntary reductions or
reducing consent
limits that where where the water is
currently not being utilized anyway
um
and so i guess to go through rather than
going through a sort of full
formal process to resolve the issue that
a steering group
of water users has been set up
and at the moment they are looking for
voluntary reductions and
consent limits from from users
so off the
back of that
we've gone through and done an analysis
on our water consumption
and looking at future expected
uh
increases in demand
um
and um
based on that i'm recommending that we
volunteer um a reduction in our consent
limits from
from currently being at 8 000 cubic
meters per day down to 7 000 cubic
meters per day
we have i have suggested some conditions
um associated with that um in those
conditions i guess are
essentially designed to make sure that
our reduced limit is as as flexible as
reasonably possible
um so that we don't have compliance
issues in the future
and also
there's a condition in there requiring
other consent holders also to reduce
their limits so that the over allocation
issue is is resolved
happy to take any questions thank you
matt steve do you want to make any
comment before i open it up
the only thing i'd say you worship is
look this is a
we recognize it's
an issue of high public interest
and normally i guess the council would
be minded to probably
preserve its negotiating position and go
into a private setting but
we the staff deliberately talked about
the public interest and needing to be up
front about what we are contemplating
doing so the public were fully
on board and engaged with the process
but the the key thing here is that
the offer
or suggestion being put forward to you
is uh predicated on the basis that
similar sacrifices will be made by other
consent holders
otherwise the council would be
preserving its current position
thank you
and i guess the
the um
the reassurance i have in the
recommendation is the
conditions that are attached if the
conditions aren't part of any
recommendation then i will be
comfortable about this
at all but certainly there is some
must-dos
to get us on board but i guess the
real risk for us is that if we don't
take part in something like this
then we may have something forced on us
anyway in fact we will have something
forced on us at some point in time
so
the risk is do we
do we take the high ground and make some
sort of
early offer
will be it with some very strong
conditions or do we just
kick it for touch and wait and see what
happens
but if nobody is going to take the
initiative then nothing will change
so council guard iron council read
completely
we have got options in the future to
take as much water as you like south of
the bridge
yeah and um we've got an old well-headed
home street isn't it but it's an it's a
risk
yeah contaminated site but i mean and
even the show grounds we can put another
whale on if we had to so basically we've
got options up our sleeve
we've got we've got options but we don't
have infrastructure that
those particular sites at this stage
council root
thank you worship um good report matt um
and i think i fully agree with the fact
that we should be leading from the front
here and just hope that um the other
people who hold water consents you know
do their bit as well but my
question for you is given the fact that
we're going to have impacts
on river flow maybe over time with
climate change um
you know
as a thousand cue mix
a big ask and do we drop that to 500
just because you know there's lots of
droughts
we've got um all sorts of things that we
don't know in 10 years time how that's
going to impact on river flow
so just before i answer your question
just to clarify are you suggesting that
we do we go for a limit of seven and a
half thousand is it yeah and you just
make it a 500
cubic difference
yeah sure um i mean
that would certainly give you
um obviously more breathing room um and
potential for further future increases
in demand
um i guess i'm
reasonably comfortable with the the
suggestion of the seven thousand cubic
meters per day and um we have sort of
certainly factored in a reasonable level
of uh growth in that seven thousand
cubic metres today
um and i guess ultimately it's it's
um if every if all consent holders are
too conservative and they're voluntary
reductions then we won't get to we won't
resolve that over allocation limit and
um and we will have to go down that that
formal process and have something forced
upon us so
yeah i mean if if you want to be really
conservative um
sure go for the seven and a half
thousand but i'm i am quite comfortable
with the seven 000.
i respect your judgment thank you
uh councilman
i think your worship um just in regard
to support with the recommendation
obviously a bit of nervousness around
anything that has water tied to it or
water usage
um i think it's important that it is
recognized from the obviously the user
group and the steering group that the
council is being transparent around what
they're indicating they're going to do
we are running slightly blind because i
can't speak to my fellow counselor but
you know what's actually coming out of
that steering group and what the
indications are and whether they're
actually providing that information into
the allocation of that water resort
resource
and
we obviously are going to indicate what
we're going to do so we're showing our
hand
i think it's a good good example it also
gives us some flexibility should they
not
come to the party or
the end result not being being seen
clearly we we obviously can reconsider
that offer my understanding from what
we're recommending here
and the other thing in regard to
supporting
uh councillor reid there the basis that
um
the 7 000 metres a day is sufficient for
us to to
push forward into the future so
i'm quite happy to move that motion
thank you council mcphail and
just before i asked for a second to
just my discussions with with matt on
this one um
really sort of revolve around that first
condition and
if we were able to get a global consent
uh to take water from both coopers and
jacobs town fields then that would give
us a huge flexibility that we don't have
now so um that would be uh something in
our favor council macdonald
are you seeking the motion oh no i just
want to ask matt a question for you i'm
quite happy seeing it but uh matt what
level of reduction are they looking for
uh the regional council they want to
we're doing about a 12 and a half
percent
are they looking for
20 or 25
what sort of level overall
have they indicated that
through your worship yeah it is
reasonably complicated um
and um i guess
um
to try and
um
i have sort of tried to cover it in my
uh report there
uh i'm just trying to find it sorry um
so
yes that's the second paragraph on page
39.
um
essentially um
each consent has different cutoff limits
and there's different allocations of
water that can be taken in those
and those um
and and river bands and in different
river bands so the the most
significantly affected river band is is
the 9 to 11 cubic flow band
currently there's 858 litres a second of
water consented
to be taken
and
under the
material water conservation order a
maximum of
577 litres per second
can be taken so to achieve that and that
river band we need a reduction of about
33
of the of the allocation
so this is significant
councillor dixon
thank you worship i mean i find all this
very disappointing from environment
south and actually because i believe
that the ghoul district council
submitted against their latest
application for water which was a jerry
farm just
north of gore
and but i understand we were at
presently
and
agree that we probably have to
allow
less water take but i'd also like to
know as the term of our consent
presently
that we have
three worship so
um we've got
um a number of different consents um to
be honest i don't know the expiry dates
off the top of my head of all of them um
i believe
so um
yeah
but not in the next few years
um that's probably the best i can do
yeah
yeah they are staggered and they will
come up from time to time i was just
wondering if that does tie us into
anything like if we put
these conditions on it would
are we still tied into a term or can we
change those conditions at any time i
think the consent is the consent
so
i would imagine
that we will be tied into those
original terms
am i right and saying that
correctly
yeah yes as far as i'm aware they
they're not looking through this process
they're not looking at considering um
extensions of
consent periods or changes to consent
periods
okay um
righto um so we have a motion is there
anybody else wants to speak to that or
do i have a secondary
our secondary counselor reed thank you
so the motion is seconded
uh any other comment from councillors
if not i'm going to put the motion all
those in favor please say aye
against
the motion is carried thank you
councillors
right we'll move on to
item 10
and
quite a big report
certainly big implications
around waste management into the future
for us and the
future possibilities for just rethinking
how we deal with
uh particularly household waste but not
just household waste
and the chief executive has put together
a pretty extensive report and i think um
covers uh you know a wide range of
ground and has some some good um
good recommendations and certainly in in
my perspective from my perspective is
the direction that we need to be moving
in
um sooner rather than later
so um mr chief executive do you want to
make any comments before i open it up
for discussion
i think it's i hope i've covered it you
worship it's reasonably self-explanatory
i mean the the purpose of the report is
really to
uh take have a contemporary stock take
on
uh waste minimization issues in
2022 given we made some
pretty fundamental decisions in 2020 and
2019 in relation to both the kerbside
recycling contract and then the
lowering of the service
almost as i said in my report to put it
on life support
given collapsing markets for
uh recyclable products and at that time
to be brutally frank
there was a vacuum of
direction coming from central government
about
where waste minimisation initiatives
were going apart from
a
very clear telegraph message that the
waste disposal levy will be rising
sharply
from now through to 2024
so this report is really a stock take
hopefully sets a platform for
some further issues to
in terms of engagement with the
community
obviously around a curbside collection
and what that might look like if it's to
be resurrected and also more importantly
or just as importantly what it might
cost
and who may do it
because
putting cows on the table
three years ago
relationships were a little bit strained
with some of the key parties we're
interfacing with
but time's right healer and part of the
process will be for if this the
recommended suite of recommendations are
endorsed by the council will be to
um
resuscitate some of those discus
relationships and discussions uh because
until such times we we have
reasonable idea of cost it's hard to
have an engagement process with a
community where you can say this is the
potential service but this is also the
cost involved
and it could both be that
given some of the
great work done by nikki boulder a
consultant
that we may have a different we may come
to a point where we want to have a
different recycling
offering
than what perhaps is currently offered
uh in south and invercargill in that
regard i'm particularly referring to
glass where
my understanding both invoke and
southland have a service where it's all
mixed together
the advice i'm getting from certain
nikki boulder is that you need to have
glass separated out if you're going to
really meaningfully recycle and there's
some promising
discussions taking place for the
potential end use for our glass
and as i said in the report you worship
some of these other
longer term initiatives like for example
a resource recovery centre they
potentially lend themselves well to a
perhaps a small working party
i understand is a very good example of
how that works in ashburton and would
probably um deserve a visit
there's nothing like seeing something in
operation being able to ask sailing
questions and then figure out how it
would actually
that type of model
some variants how that might work on the
ground but certainly we're well poised
now and the government coming out with
the direction it has
i think it's such a chance for the camp
for the community to start to
um
re-imagine how we deal with waste and
get ourselves ready for what's going to
be a sharp er increase in
landfill tariffs within the next two
years
thanks steve and
as i said before i think this is the
direction that we need to be moving in
as as a council
and as a community i think the probably
one of the key factors in the success of
going down the strategy is the
appointment of a waste minimisation
officer somebody to take control and um
and really drive this particular project
and and with that and with a number of
other things that will come cost but
actually doing nothing comes with a cost
and it's only going to be an increasing
cost so
um
it's there probably is no choice at the
end of the day but look i'll open this
up for counsellors i'm interested in
your thoughts and getting a clear
direction for the community on this this
particular issue
so
who's first councillor dixon
thank you worship um what i'm wondering
is what our options would be for
recycling ourselves and gore without the
cost of transporting it to invercargill
and the cost of recycling it there
we could employ people to separate out
the glass there is a lot of food waste i
think 24
of their waste is food and a lot of
methane comes off that food waste we've
got steel we've got the three
different types of plastic that can be
recycled i'm just wondering if we should
be looking
at that
and costing all that out with sending it
to invercargill as well because i think
mcgregor concrete takes glass
also
for a small fee and then um in the back
so
just thinking about all of that and the
other thing i'd like to say is that um
should we call this officer a waste
minimisation and recycling officer so
that it all
ties it in together i mean they can look
into different options for as you say
ashburton is a good option
thank you
uh yeah and thanks for those
observations council dixon um yeah look
certainly one of the key
uh questions posed um
by nikki boulder to me in discussion
just in discussions was look
you might want to do it yourself
yeah and
so that's a very live option uh
depending on where we get to with um
talking through the issues with uh icc
and
recycle south and it may well be that
our needs are just simply a bit
different
and the material distance maybe uh we
might do something ourselves so that
they're all
very much live options and
the reference to mcgregor's and glasses
that's one that's actually being
advanced
literally as we speak to try and see if
we can do something there that can not
just collect the glass but actually
crush it and have it reused and this is
a big point of the government's
strategic policy setting is that they
talk about a circular economy to try and
keep things
circulating and being reused as opposed
to ending up in a landfill and costing
us plenty
and i guess
the the idea the concept of a resource
recovery park
fits that model incredibly well and i
think that we could do that quite
quickly
and and i'm pretty sure that there would
be quite a number of volunteers in our
community would love to be part of
something like that
okay um
yeah yeah recycling big thing you go
through the country and other people
seem to be recycling um i think we
should be doing it ourselves especially
the plastics like we have a company in
new zealand called um
future posts that take a lot of these
plastics chip them down and turn them
into fence posts and sleepers and stuff
like that
um i think we do need a food waste bin
for businesses there's a lot of scraps
out there
we could be utilizing that for our own
compost and stuff as well um
like invicago has like a drop-in center
where you can actually drop appliances
off that are still working or bikes and
lights all this stuff does gore look at
that too because a lot of things go over
the face that probably could be reused
by somebody so there's probably an area
we can probably look at that as well um
probably a good time reminders for the
public and we can advertise where what
your waste computers and cell phones and
other things can be dropped off um
around gore as well instead of filling
out the landfill
thank you
nick and certainly that
that concept is very much part of the
resource recovery park and and it works
well in other areas so there's no reason
why it wouldn't work well here
councillor reed yeah further to that you
worship too i know that there are people
in our community who have skills at
recycling and repurposing and are very
keen
to have some input and would probably
volunteer their time quite happily to be
a part of that
so i'd be really keen to see that
recovery park up and sorted as fast as
possible
councillor davis
i think your worship i'm just wondering
with the budget that we currently have
with waste minimisation that goes
to the region
have we looked at that
in relation to this because
in that package that we send down
to the regional
this
waste minimisation officer that we part
pay where we did
pay for a waste minimisation officer in
there there's other costs that we pay
towards
that
we haven't possibly used
since we've changed our recycling and i
just think that budget needs to be
checked off against this budget because
we'll end up doubling up yeah
you look you you've made some some good
points there nikki and the whole um
concept of waste net uh
personally i think needs to be um
rethought uh it hasn't functioned that
well for quite some time now and there's
a variety of reasons for that but i
think
sort of a regional strategy with
regional coordination but local delivery
is is something that we need to be
focusing on as much as we possibly can
if i can just add to that um i see that
you're
thinking about uh progressing
discussions within the cargo city but we
were part of this with south and
district council also yeah so
what's the plan with south and just so
um so i'll ask steve to give a bit of an
update on that but
um initially
us and southern district pulled out of
the centre uh and my understanding is
that south and district have contracted
back to the cargo city to to do that as
opposed to doing it themselves that's
right
yeah that's correct you worship so south
and district council they say they
icc have a like a subcontract with sdc
so icc have the contractual relationship
with recycle south and or the old s
south and disability enterprises
and then so south and just purely
interface with icc so
part of the proposal was to
talk to icc about you know what would
as one of the options what would a
potential contract of gdc with icc look
like and cost
and that was in your point uh council
davis about
the existing waste net budget and
obligations they need to go into the mix
of the ultimate report that comes back
to the council so we say well what are
we what are we actually paying for what
are we getting is there a spare capacity
that can be reassigned
to give us a better option that suits
our needs
i i'm thinking that
potentially
we if we get down to this particular
point that it may be that our needs are
more refined
than say iccs and stcs you're mixing the
glass with other stuff and it could be
that we may forge your own path but it
behooves us to have the discussion put
the potential costs on the table and put
it forward as an option for
consideration
yeah in that contract with waste net
that we
are currently in there's a number of
things that are duplicated across the
region such as education going out to
schools all that kind of thing waste
minimisation is part of it we pay for a
waste modernisation officer to go
through willy bins
so that's all part of it and and we've
obviously still been paying for that
i gather so
it does behoove council to really look
at what we are paying for and what we're
getting yeah yeah thank you
yeah
my understanding and put me right on um
wrong here my understanding is there
there is a general
willingness of the three councils in
southland to rethink waste net
it was it was useful when it was created
uh worked for quite some time and it
hasn't been working well lately it needs
to be rethought councillor phillips
thank you your issue uh i'm just here
with thinking about
that if we're going to go down the track
of our own uh recycling that perhaps
we should be thinking also expanding
our services to the to our district
because there are
probably local streets that are not
within the curbside collection that may
be available to
get revenue from you know that are close
and handy
you know like
if the truck was to extend itself
another 500 meters or so
further out on a street line um you know
like it's all revenue for us not only in
the rating of the bins but also in the
in the curbside collection itself yeah
that that certainly should be part of
any consideration and personally for
himself now we're talking about um
the the recycling bins in gwara matara
but yeah surely we need to be thinking
about the urban areas of waikaka and and
pukarao as well which are not part of
that
particular scenario
just okay could i just comment to that
till you worship as
having family that live in waikaka they
bring their recycling into gore um when
they come in so yeah we do need to be
supporting them and recycling
okay council hosted
you thank you we're just looking at the
recommendation the steps we're working
through the where does the waste
minimization officer decision where does
that sit in terms of timeline is that a
decision that's made now or is it post
feedback from icc some costing work and
the decision to move to
to um engaging with the community
where does that fit
um steve
i guess uh through your worship i gave
the council a little bit of wriggle room
in terms of timing hints just give
consideration to as opposed to you must
but uh
look realistically you can see there's
quite a bit of body of work here
um and
we need
a person with a certain skill set to
help propel us we've got now jason on
board that's great
my personal view is that i don't think
employing a waste minimisation officer
needs to be kind of
conditional upon engaging with the
community engagement community is about
kerbside recycling recovery center
talking about what's coming at us in
regards to the tariff the higher tariffs
at landfill and the fact that we need to
change the government direction all that
stuff
that to me
is writ large that we need a dedicated
person and what is a pretty decent sized
activity in its own right that it
doesn't have a dedicated officer
timing-wise i mean i'm acutely aware
that we've
only just signed off on our annual plan
and it may well be that it has to be
deferred as a item of priority for next
year's annual plan
we can survive till then but we we
certainly need to
um and i'm sure that jason myself can
get a lot of stuff going
but when you look at the range of
activities and
uh actually when you get starting to
execute a new service and put it on the
ground and actually someone actually can
do all that engagement and
iron out the teething problems
that does suggest that you need a
dedicated officer in charge
so
it's really
i guess over to the council to determine
the urgency of the issue
and how readily it wants a dedicated
resource in place
but it can ultimately wait until next
year's annual plan
okay
council davis
thank you worship i've just been
thinking if you're looking at doing
field trips for
recovery centres wanaka has a really
good one
that the community run and and it's
really well oiled so that might be one a
little bit closer to home that that you
could potentially go and look at
yep
absolutely
okay so on the point of that should we
should the recommendation include that
that officer be included in the annual
plan obviously if anything changes in
the interim um before annual plan time
no doubt the officers will bring that
back to the council's attention would
that be logical
okay
have we covered the issues is there
anything uh councilman mcfarlane
just in regard to that um where the
recommendation came through from the
ahika i think it was a report
we've got that tagged back to the fact
that we're going to look at trying to
recoup some money through levies through
the government levies
that was part of
the minimalisation role we did have that
flag somewhere didn't we just confirm
yeah
i know i don't think it's actually
outlined in that
recommendation
from her nikki's report
so
just confirming that that is there
certainly take note of that
okay with that in mind and
with that change regarding uh
consideration
of the
waste minimisation officer to occur at
uh annual plan time
would somebody like to move the
recommendation council dixon i was
saying to councillor davis thank you
i guess it's semantics i'm
we can finalize this position yeah um
at the time so
through your worship i mean the waste
minimization officer was a term that's
been
uh banded around by the likes of nicki
bolder in her report and others and
myself included but
it could be that we have a slight
deviation from that suggestion when we
ultimately come to scoping the job
putting out a job description so
i don't think ministerial wedded to
waste minimisation obviously although i
do get that the more it flows off the
tongue the more it embeds itself in the
psyche
of us all but if if the council's got
strong feelings and wants recycling
there look that can happen nicely
okay thank you and it's been seconded
councillor davis
any further discussion councillors does
not i'll put the motion all those in
favor please say aye
gates the motion is carried thank you
councillors that's
certainly a big step forward in that
particular area look i think that brings
us to the end of the open agenda am i
right and saying that yes okay
so
we do have some items to be
discussed outside of the open